mics in Lansing Michigan hey Mike
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey how
are you doing Dave
better than I deserve what's up yeah hey
real quick just want to say thank you
for everything that you do you've
changed you know my personal in the way
that we run our business but I've got a
question for you
I own a lawn and a landscape company and
a snow company up here in Michigan and
you know I'm really having trouble I've
been doing this for about 11 years and
having trouble with the caliber employee
that we you know typically see and just
how do we find a thoroughbred
in a sea of donkeys as you well yeah
well you have to create a couple of
things that are different than all the
other lawncare guys mm-hmm you have to
create a different environment and why
would someone want to work there okay
and part of its pay it just straight up
the more you pay the better person you
have a chance to get you know it's that
simple
but there we were having a discussion
the other day when we did an entree
leadership theme our Daniel tardy in our
he's the scene or the executive vice
president of that area with a guy on the
air that had an ice cream shop and we
were thinking of places like
southwestern books and and chick-fil-a
where what they do is they employ
college students and the collet the
reason the high quality college student
wants to do those work our high school
students want to do that work is the
environment that they're in they're
being trained it's almost as if that if
you if you find someone that has sold
books for Southwest you have found
someone that can survive in a sales job
and prosper in a sales job it's like a
boot camp for selling and so an example
might be that if if families of high
character in the Lansing area
new Mike's landscaping business was a
place that their son would work and
would be taught how to be a man a man of
high character and a man of work and the
environment was clean in terms of the
character of cleanliness not obviously
you get dirty mowing grass imma tell ya
I'm gonna talk about that but I'm
talking about it's not you know it's not
a bunch of filthy mouths filthy stuff
filthy people doing filthy habits that
their kid is running with and if young
men knew that they could come to work
for you and be mentored on business
principles and on character that would
set them up to succeed later in life you
would have a constant turnover because
as they grew up or go back to college
you'd lose them but you'd have a
constant feeder of every parent not
every parent a lot of parents want their
kid to work at chick-fil-a not because
they want to teach them to do chicken
but because of what they learn about
life and customer service and it's a
clean and safe environment in terms of
character and the way the child the way
the young person is treated and you know
you meet some of the most sparkling
wonderful teenagers in the world when
you walk into one of those places as a
consequence and so you create a brand
differentiation rather than just we cut
grass and we pay minimum wage you know
we pay good but you're gonna have an
experience here I mean we I don't you
know I'm a person of faith and so if it
were me doing it I'd be going hey we
have a Bible study it's not mandatory
but we're Bible study on Wednesday
mornings you know or Wednesday evenings
when we finish up work or whatever and
you know there's not a bunch of
drunkards working on this team and not a
bunch of pot smokers working on this
team you know we're gonna be these are
men young men of valor young men of
character and that's who you get to run
with and you will become a better
and a young man as a result of having
worked here that's how I would present
it and then you know reach out and
you'll get some older guys that want to
stay with you forever and participate in
that and they want to be mentors to
these younger guys something like that
or you could go a different way but
that's just an example of you're caught
you built a cultural differentiator that
makes you attractive not because of the
exact work you're doing or the pay of
course the other thing you can do is you
could say hey you know we pay X number
of dollars and you know we pay bonuses
on production and bonuses are off it or
whatever so we've done a performance
bonus at 50 cents per hour for your pay
period you know if we get good
performance and also attendance bonus so
you have the ability to earn an extra
dollar an hour on your base pay that's
wrong but in my dependent upon their
emotional position that they emotionally
act like they own the place which which
tells me how they cut the grass how they
interact with the owner how they treat
the equipment you know how they shop for
the best price on fuel to go in the
equipment whatever I mean they're gonna
act like they own this place and the
more they do that the more you can
afford to pay them right and and the
less hassle you got running the business
but one of our core values on the wall
is we are all self-employed and it's
just typed on them it's a big old
letters on the back wall of our meeting
room you know and we remind our folks
all the time you technically work on
someone else's team but everyone in this
world is self-employed in you know what
when you work for somebody else you just
happen to have one client you know you
know yeah but that's you just get that
kind of vibe going and and and then it's
still a dogfight to this day one of our
biggest things we spend time money and
effort on is the finding of
thoroughbreds and we're gonna you know
we're in a white collar highly appealing
situations and we have all these other
advantages you know but it's still we
have to get people in here that care
that have talent and smarts and the care
and that have character and the care you
know it's just a lot of people just want
to come to work and mail it in you know
and so you know that you end up they'd
end up leaving this place because they
don't fit in around here so it just
takes it's a constant thing the human
resource in a business is the the most
expensive line item on your pl in almost
every business it's the thing you invest
the most in it's the thing that gives
you the most return that is the most
rewarding emotionally spiritually and
psychologically and it's the most
draining financially emotionally
psychologically spiritually it's the
thing that makes me cry for joy the most
often and the thing that makes me cry
tears of Terror the most often and and
it's just it's the sweet and sour sauce
of business baby
it ain't for sissies so I'm going to
send you a copy of Ken Coleman's new
book the proximity principle because
you're not looking for a job but you get
your business and the people inside your
business in the proximity and you get
yourself in the proximity of these
thoroughbreds and that's how you find
them so I would use this book is about
the proven strategy that will lead to
the career you love it's about someone
looking for a job but I think you could
use these exact same principles turn
them on their head and use them to look
for people to hire and and I think it's
something to think about
so just a good discussion thanks for
calling in with that we discussed this
kind of stuff folks all the time with
small business people all over America
the whole entree leadership brand the
all-access membership for entree
leadership the whole process of plugging
in with them with a team there and
coming to the events but also the online
coaching and online mastermind groups
and everything else we've got with that
it's a constant thing we coached small
businesses because people like Mike
right there that's how America works the
guy call a little bit earlier in the
hour started with a $1,500 truck now I
did 15 million dollars you hear him yeah
I mean those are those men and women
like that they're what make America
great man as far as the economy goes
it's a they are the backbone of the
economy